Alaska believe it or not suffered its
third deadly plane crash in just over a
week one person was killed and two
others were hurt when the plane went
down yesterday in Prince William Sound
that crash follows two other recent
crashes and Don Dahler is here with more
Don good morning good morning the
National Transportation Safety Board is
investigating the cause of the crash the
Coast Guard responded to yesterday's
crash around 2:00 p.m. after a Cessna
aircraft went down into the water near
cascade Bay people in boats nearby
pulled three people from the water one
person died two others were airlifted to
the hospital it happened the same day a
small Alaskan plane company grounded all
of its flights following two deadly
crashes that killed eight people
in just a week on Monday a float plane
owned by two Kwan Air crashed in
Metlakatla on a commuter flight both
passengers on board were killed and last
week another Taquan plane collided
midair with another aircraft in
Ketchikan killing six people and
injuring ten others the NTSB told CBS
News seeing crashes involving the same
company doesn't mean there is safety
issues with the operator it's pilots nor
the aircraft itself there's a lot of
flights like that up there going on all
there's a lot of roads so that's they're
like cars but don't just bring in the
three in a short time is that's
surprising yes yeah it makes you nervous
gale won't be going on